let's talk about what's happening in
Israel and
[Music]
Gaza a massive surprise attack on Israel
by Hamas the group that controls Gaza
has quickly escalated into the most
intense conflict in decades an
unprecedented military operation by
Hamas and a colossal failure of Israeli
intelligence you had all these gunmen
entering up to 22 different locations
outside the Gaza strips Israel says
hundreds of its citizens have been
killed and many more injured the violent
Israeli raids have not stopped
bombarding across the Gaza Strip there's
so much going on so we're going to
answer three questions to help you
understand what's happening this is Gaza
it's a small strip of Palestinian land
that's been under a land sea and air
blockade by Israel since 2007 more than
2 million Palestinians live there
crammed in and they can only leave with
Israeli permission which few people get
it's often referred to as the world's
largest open air prison
and Hamas is the political and armed
group that runs
Gaza it took control there after it won
an election in 2006 but there hasn't
been a vote since then Hamas is part of
a regional Alliance that also includes
Iran and the armed group Hezbollah in
Lebanon Israel the US EU and others have
designated Hamas a terrorist
organization many Palestinians see Hamas
as the most active group when it comes
to resistance against Israeli occupation
especially since the other main
Palestinian political group fat which
controls parts of the West Bank is often
criticized for being ineffective now
Israel and Hamas have fought on andof
Wars the last big one was in 2021 in the
past it's usually been an exchange of
fire across the Gaza border Hamas fires
Rockets into Israel Israel drops bombs
on Gaza usually with a huge civilian
death
toll but what happened this time around
was very different a lot of people are
calling it unprecedented why well really
because of the scale of the attack that
Hamas launched and because nobody really
saw it coming it started early on
October 7th Hamas fired thousands of
rockets into Israel and then sent
hundreds of Fighters over the Border
they overran a border crossing and broke
down the security barrier that surrounds
Gaza with
bulldozers some Fighters were in
vehicles some even flew over on
motorized
paragliders they attacked towns and
Villages at least 900 Israelis were
killed and including around 260 at a
music festival videos online showed
panicked people trying to
escape Hamas also says it's captured
more than a 100 Israelis including some
senior Military Officers Israel says
children and elderly women were also
taken nothing like that has happened
since Hamas captured one Israeli soldier
gillad Shalit in 2006 and held him in
Gaza for 5 years 3 days after Hamas
launched its attack there were still gun
batt battles going on between Hamas
Fighters and Israeli forces in three
main areas in southern Israel which
brings us to another reason why this is
also unprecedented and that's Israel's
failure to stop it remember the Israeli
Army is one of the world's most
sophisticated military and intelligence
organizations and the border with Gaza
is heavily monitored so this attack came
as a huge shock
unfortunately uh we were taken by
surprise absolute surprise any kind of
communication going in and out of G
at least in theory would be listened to
by Israel's intelligence units and of
course the border socaled around Gaza a
wall and fence is also highly
militarized but clearly clearly that
collapse I think it raises questions as
to Israel's military capability which
isn't a good look for Israel since it l
likes to be uh seen as the strong man
and Incredibly capable in in that region
Israel has also vowed an unprecedented
response and says it plans to wipe out
hamas's Military capability and end its
control of
Gaza Israel's been hitting Gaza hard
with air strikes and
artillery all right yumna please take
cover no it's okay
um this is a mile attack on on Palestine
Tower there have been pictures coming
out showing Devastation and bodies being
pulled out from from the rubble more
than 700 people have been killed
including
children
yes um there this is just an air strike
now that you've heard uh it seems that
it's very close here from the area of
where we are we're at
neighborhood this is the fourth mosque
to be bombarded bombarded in the Gaza
Strip remember Gaza is really densely
populated civilians there are trapped
with nowhere to escape to there was
already a blockade there but now Israel
has imposed a total Siege on Gaza which
amounts to Collective punishment making
it illegal under international law
and Israel has called up 300,000 Army
reservists and it looks like the ground
invasion of Gaza is also imminent in
front of me I can see soldiers coming in
on Humvees Jeeps rain Rovers we are
seeing an increasing troop build up okay
so why has all this happened now well
there's a clue in the name Hamas gave
for its attack operation Al AXA flood
just days before hundreds of Israeli
settlers with the protection of Israeli
forces stormed aloa mosque compound and
occupied East Jerusalem this is a hugely
important and contested religious site
it's often a flash point in the Israeli
Palestinian conflict we've done another
star here episode all about that we'll
put a link to it in the comments now
Hamas said it launched its attack in
response to the desecration of
alaka but even if recent events at alaka
played a role hamas's huge attack would
have taken a lot of planning they also
say the attack was a response to Decades
of Israeli violence and occupation the
daily impact of that occupation on the
lives of Palestinians inside Gaza and in
other occupied territories like the West
Bank is also a big part of the story
analysts and experts have been warning
for months that the reality on the
ground the record number of Palestinians
killed dispossessed and injured and
traumatized by Israeli forces and
settlers
across the occupied West Bank the
continued Siege on Gaza the Relentless
attacks on they were all pushing uh the
situation towards this moment I don't
think anybody imagined um the
particulars of the moment but I think
everybody with a sense of what was going
on knew uh that this calm was deceiving
and that uh um something was going to
happen something big the whole world is
watching this all unfold right now
there's a huge focus on the human cost
but there's also a growing sense that
this is all going to shift things in the
region in a big way there's a risk that
could lead to an even bigger regional
conflict it could draw a country like
Iran which Israel says helped to
orchestrate the attack although Iran
denies they were involved in any way but
underlying it are even bigger questions
that have never been answered and can no
longer be ignored what does real peace
actually look like for everyone and how
can we get there it's possible and
necessary to stand with both the
Palestinians and
Israelis uh without resorting to ethical
relativism to selective outrage or Worse
calls for violence politicians policy
makers should prioritize restoring
legality and accountability using
diplomacy and peace as conflict
resolution methods rather than
advocating for more violence all
standing
with one side or another start here did
a recent episode explaining why the aloa
Moss compound is so significant we've
linked it
[Music]
here